hey there townscaper so i was asked a
really interesting question someone
asked me how do you zoom into
really tall buildings and i can see why
they were asked that because if you're
just getting into the game and you play
something else the controls can be
a little wonky they could be a little
intimidating a perfect example of this
would be the sims 4. the controls are
literally inverted so it makes for some
really interesting first time gameplay
you want to rotate your camera but you
end up panning it like this or you want
to pan your camera but you end up
rotating
it like this so yeah i'm going to keep
this short as possible i'm going to go
over the camera controls and then we'll
get into the zooming part so obviously
to zoom in and out you want to use the
middle scroll button
if you want to rotate your camera you
want to take your left click button
and you want to just drag it this is me
rotating to the left just me rotating to
the right
of course you pull your mouse down while
you're holding the left click if you
want a bird's eye view
and if you want a full frontal view you
just go on ahead and push your mouse
upwards so if you want to pin
you want to hold your right click button
this is me panning to the left this is
me panning to the right
and if you want to move it upwards you
just drag it up
if you want to move it down you just
move it down so to get started
let's just start from all the way in the
back if you zoom the camera all the way
in the back
and you pan your camera to the bottom
and you zoom in you'll notice that
you'll go all the way to the base of
your build
this is about the fourth story third and
fourth story so if you want to get to
the middle all you have to do of course
is pan your camera using the right click
button so i'm taking my right click
button and i'm dragging the camera
upwards i just took my left click button
so that i can rotate and adjust to
center view
and now i'm at about the 10th story if
i'm not mistaken one two three four five
six
seven eight nine ten is the tenth story
if you want to go even further
of course all you have to do is take
your right click button
and drag the camera upwards of course
you're gonna take your left click and
you're gonna
adjust it and now you're at the top of
the building now this
is a pretty simple example because
um this building is actually pretty
short this is about
20 20 stories i have an example right
here
um i believe it's about 60 stories
please don't quote me because i count it
like three times and so this is it right
here
and just going to show you that example
again i'm zooming all the way out
i've pinned my camera to the bottom so
as soon as you zoom in it's going to
take you right to the base of the build
this is the third story
uh and of course if you zoom out and you
panned up
at this point the building's so tall
that you're basically scaling it to get
to the top you can zoom out
and now you're basically your camera's
at center
point if you will and you zoom in and
you're right at the middle of it you
take your left click button and you
center it if you want to get all the way
to the top for a building like this
i highly recommend that you just zoom
all the way out take your right click
button
pan it as far as you can like you see
how i'm scaling all the way to the top i
can't even pull the mouse down anymore
and then zoom in and boom there you have
it uh take the left click button to
rotate so you can see what you have
going on
and you can take it to bird's eye view
thing about bird's eye view
in tall buildings is that of course with
any building you're going to hit the top
you're going to hit the roof but once
you zoom out it'll only go so far
until of course you increase the size of
the building
and then the camera will adjust so what
i noticed about this
it's perfect because it it can work out
to make for some
really nice pictures if you practice it
zoom in pretty well i'll show you an
example right here like try to get to
this staircase
so wasd those help you go forward back
left right you want to get in as
as close as possible so i'm just going
to go through the controls as i do this
right now i'm using the right click
button to pan the camera
i can't zoom in anymore i've literally
zoomed in as much as i could so i'm
going to take the left click button i'm
going to take the left click
and i'm going to drag it
and try to get in as much as possible i
just use the
w key or the up key i'm still using the
left click
now i'm using the right click to pull
pull it i'm adjusting
i'm moving in a little further with the
directional button
now you can kind of see the the
staircase right here but you still need
a little bit of adjusting so i'm right
clicking i'm pulling it back
then i take the left click button i kind
of tilt it
i'm pushing the w key or you can use the
up key to get me closer
i'm left clicking and i'm panning the
camera
while rotating the camera downwards if
you will and now i'm panning as close as
i possibly can
this is as close as we can get this is
me pushing w
um now i'm pushing s to go backwards so
yeah this makes for really really great
up close pictures
so take that in and make some really
great townscaper photos
so that's it for today if this video
helped you out please make sure that you
like and share to help me out if you
haven't subscribed go ahead and hit that
button it'll help me out as well and i
really appreciate the support you guys
if you haven't seen my two series the
random clicking series or the connecting
small town
series please check those out they
should pop up in the cards in the top
right corner of the video here
but anyways i just want to thank you
guys so much for viewing um it's greatly
appreciated
please make sure that you check out my
content make sure that you like
subscribe and comment
i'll see you next time